indeed this is my fourth time here I I
don't know why I keep I keep getting
invited back I think each year the the
the talks getting more technical and
less accessible so maybe I'll keep I'll
continue that trend and then until I
don't get until I don't get invited back
let's see if this thing and see if this
thing works does this work no aha
very good oh no the punchline so so this
month actually marks the it's been it's
been now over over ten years since I
started down the crazy path the rabbit
hole of building what are now called
data science tools they weren't called
they weren't called that back that they
weren't called that back then maybe I
shouldn't have had a beer but so I
started writing the lines of code that
became the pandas project in April in
April 2008 and it's been kind of a wild
kind of a wild ride since then I handed
over the reins of the the project to you
know Geoffrey back and the other
maintainer is and in 2013 and they've
been doing a great job the last five
years you know keeping the project you
know growing and healthy and that
continues you know to the to the present
day I've gotten involved in some other
open-source projects in the in the
Apache Software Foundation started a
couple of other small projects wrote a
book did a second dition I had a startup
so it's been the it's been an
interesting and interesting ride I I'm
still here I'm still I'm still building
data science tools so I haven't been you
know I haven't been thrown off the train
quite quite yet but I've spent a lot of
time thinking about the you know now
with the perspective of looking at the
last the last 10 years and how far we've
come with open source data science tools
and my theme you know if you look at my
talks here at the our conference the
last two or three years I've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
you know where are we going over the
next 10 years over the next 20 years and
how can we plan and work together to
to build a better you know a better
future for for ourselves and so I wrote
I wrote a talk at the end of 2013 I gave
it at PI data NYC and the title of the
talk was 10 things I hate about pandas
and so I you know like as we've been
building the into the software you you
know you know about all of the things
that are not good and so I've tried to
kind of distill all of that learning and
complaints and grievances and turn it
into something productive and maybe
build some useful some useful software
that can put us on a better better
trajectory to build better data science
tools in the future so so one one step
that I've just taken this this year is
so I've founded an organization called
Ursa labs hopefully the reason behind
the name should be should be obvious but
in general funding open-source software
is very complicated and it's it's tough
because people struggle with giving
money to fund open-source developers so
I think there's you know like many
people they just they download the
software they use it but they don't
think a lot about how is that software
produced like who are the people that
are that are producing it and it has
been incredibly difficult for
individuals who are building projects to
obtain full time you know no strings
attached support for for building for
building the projects that they're that
they're most passionate about and I
personally have been through several
iterations of different approaches to
obtaining sustainable sustainable
funding to work on to work on my
projects including including pandas and
you know pandas was primarily Funt was
self-funded it came out of money out of
my own pocket and money that I could
have been making doing consulting or
working in a you know here in New York
and a financial firm so I'd be much
wealthier if I did not work on open
source software but I just felt it was
the right thing to do and I was willing
to make willing to make that sacrifice
I've done some other things I've done
consulting supported open source
development
I did found a venture-backed startup
with the intent of you know funding R&D
time back into the open source ecosystem
that brought with it its own challenges
and and kind of difficulties that come
with you know they come with startups
I've worked on open source projects
within inside a larger company so the
last four years I've been I've been with
cloud era and and with two sigma so this
so starting a lab so I'm partnering up
with with with our studio to to build
the lab so get to work formally with mr.
Hadley Wickham you know for the for the
first time we've worked together
informally in the past but this will be
the first time that we get to work on a
project together but the idea is that we
are you know creating an organization to
be able to raise to raise money from
companies that depend on open source
data science tools and that money will
be used directly to fund salary and
benefits for full-time developers who or
who are building projects to make the
whole you know Python are you know
general data science ecosystem
stronger and better I've last few years
I've been building a project helping
build a project called Apache arrow so a
lot of this work will be based on on
arrow for some reasons that I will talk
about over the next 15 minutes and the
goal is to create software that is
portable and promotes collaboration and
software use across the data science
world so that we aren't simply solving
problems that our programmers have or
the Python programmers have that we're
creating reusable software that can
benefit the entire open-source data
science world and I think that as time
goes on it will get easier and easier
for for that collaboration to to happen
so so I'm the director of the lab Hadley
is advising and making sure that I make
fewer mistakes and that the needs of the
our community are are looked after and
we are going to work together to because
really you know if you look at what
Hadley and I do we design we think about
the human interface with data and so a
lot of people thought oh well Haley and
I are
we should be enemies because we build
Python and our tools but really what we
do is we look at how data scientists
work and we want to make their lives
better it's like how can we make the
individual more productive able to spend
you know more time thinking about data
science and solving problems less time
thinking about code so if we can
translate our ideas about working with
data into code that is easy to reason
about and easy to write that makes you
know the whole you know the whole world
more productive and more effective and
so over the years you know he and I have
have bonded over our kind of passion for
making people more productive working
with data and so I think you know
collaborating on on these projects will
you know the whole will be greater than
the sum of its parts for sure so the
last couple of years I've been with two
Sigma's so they're they're sponsoring
and and important helping support
support this work our studio is is
taking on the administrative burden of
operating the lab so so when I so when I
hire people into the lab they'll make
that a lot easier on me so that I do not
have to spend all my time running a
company and we are you know going to be
fundraising and looking for more
sponsors and development partners to to
get involved so if you have a budget for
sponsoring open-source and would be
interested in and getting involved
please please get in touch
we love to we'd love to hear from you so
now let's get into some slightly more
technical matter so my talks here the
last two are New York our conferences
have been about arrow you know it
started out like here's a project that
just started here's some pie-in-the-sky
ideas that we're really excited about
last year it was hey we've made some
progress on those ideas and now we've
made a lot more progress and so things
are starting to get really really
exciting so I think a year from now if
I'm invited back I'll have I'll have
more more to tell about about what's
going on but but the idea of the project
is that we identified in my work on on
pandas a lot of problems that I was I
was running into
you know how do I share data with this
data processing system or you know why
am I having to reinvent the wheel to
read CSV files and to read data out of
databases efficiently and so you know
kind of if you look at the pandas
project it's this whole world unto
itself where we've had to solve all of
these data access data manipulation
computational problems for ourselves we
aren't able to take code from the our
world and reuse it or code from the Java
world and reuse it and so I kind of
drill down and said you know how can we
build some technology that could enable
us to share data and share algorithms
more easily so I spent while I was at
Cloudera I spent about a year trying to
get get folks together kind of get a
band together to to build a project to
see if people also agreed other people
agree that this was a problem luckily
they did and we were able to you know
get together you know 25 or 30
open-source developers to create the you
know to create the aero project and
we've been growing the the team the team
since then so one of the highest and the
biggest you know kind of most important
use cases for for Apache aero is you
know what I called defragmenting data
access so if you think about the problem
well you got all these computational
systems all of these data storage
formats data access points the points of
contact for data access so there's a lot
of energy loss dealing with like how do
I get data from point A to point B how
do I convert between one systems memory
representation and another systems
memory representation and so legacy
systems still may use a native memory
memory representation that is not Aero
but they can retrofit themselves to be
able to support Aero export and import
and that will make things a lot simpler
for systems that want to plugin that
also speak speak aero and as time goes
on when new data processing engines are
developed we we expect and hope that
systems will choose choose arrow as
their native format for for analytics in
in memory so I think if this is the
portable data frame problem so you know
we say data frame like you know our data
frame pandas dataframe Giulia data frame
but if you drill down below just the
language into the technical details of
like when I say data frame like what
actually is that thing if you look in
you know the DRAM in your computer how
has that memory arranged in you know
virtual address space and an our data
frame at that level is completely
different from a panda's data frame it's
completely different from a spark data
frame and so forth so the idea of arrow
is to define a language independent data
frame representation that is suitably
general to address you know 99% of use
cases for data frame like tools and have
native implementations across the gamut
of programming languages that are used
to build data science tools so if we are
in the python r ecosystem we can write
code in c c++ if you're in you know a
different ecosystem you might be writing
code in java or rust or go or javascript
so so arrow is not specific to any any
programming language so there's some
some major use cases where the project
is is getting picked up and in the world
so one is as a primary runtime memory
format for analytics so when you load
data from files or you pull data out of
databases to do some data manipulations
or perform some analytics the data is
arranged in memory and arrow format and
so then you run your algorithms on on on
the arrow memory and what's exciting
about having this runtime format is that
if I have an algorithm that knows how to
process arrow memory that that algorithm
is automatically reusable so you know
it's very difficult right now if I write
an algorithm that processes a panda's
data frame I can't take that code and
process an our data frame because the
memory is different
using the same technology we've been
developing tools to enable data to be
shared between processes without copying
so this is about making it really cheap
and easy to access very large data sets
and to blur the boundary between data
and memory and data on disk so if you
have a really huge data set that is on
your laptop on a solid-state drive maybe
it's a terabyte of data maybe it's 100
gigabytes of data maybe there's only a
small chunk of that data that you want
to use to for your analysis with a lot
of data serialization tools in order to
access that subset of data for your
analysis you have to read the whole data
set so if it might be like the middle of
a CSV file so you have to parse the
whole CSV file before you can get that
middle chunk so arrow makes that that
problem go away where you can just you
know access only the data that you need
and you can get access to that very
cheaply we've been using we've been
using arrow to build file formats so you
may have heard of this thing called
feather that that Hadley and I made so
that was a first example of building a
file format that that uses arrow and I
think that I think that we'll see more
of that that sort of thing you know
develop and in the next couple of years
and so I know in the our world there's a
there's another competing file format
with feather called
called FST and so the way I would
contrast or way I would describe FST is
as an evolved version of feather that
can only be read and are and so from my
point of view like having file formats
that can be read in any programming
languages is a you know kind of that's
that's really what I would what I would
like to see one of the biggest the the
project has grown so much is it's no
longer just about data frames and
columnar data but the columnar data
format is one of the biggest parts of
the project where we spent the most time
designing a suitably general and
efficient data frame representation for
for analytics so I won't go through
these details but these are things you
can read more about we've been building
libraries and many programming languages
so we started out with Java and C++ we
now have a native JavaScript
implementation it's really cool it can
you can generate it a narrow file and in
Java or Python and send it to the
browser and read it without doing any
parsing so it doesn't go through JSON or
any of that and and that's really neat
we just received a donation of a go
implementation which was created by
influx data which which builds in flux
DB I need to update this diagram because
we
have a burgeoning rust native rust
implementation which is really cool I
know there's also a Julia implementation
somewhere in the ether that I hope can
get merged into the into the Apache
project and we've been building bindings
so I've been working on and with you
know many other people on Python
bindings there's also Ruby bindings
which are kind of it's like kind of a
conception where it's like bindings on
bindings so Ruby is going through C
which is talking to C++ so you know it's
you know you have bindings - binding -
bindings starting to see arrow used in
some pretty cool applications so if you
follow work happening in the Berkeley
Ryze lab which is oriented around real
time secure machine learning they've
developed a machine learning framework
called ray which uses they developed a
shared memory object store for managing
data that flows between tasks in a in a
reinforcement learning setting and so
that object store is called plasma and
they donated that to the to the arrow
project and it's become a tightly
integrated component so that we can see
more machine learning systems built on
top of the mantra of free data access
and shared and shared memory which these
libraries make make so you know much
simpler than doing it doing it by hand
many companies in industry have been
have been contributing to the
contributing to the project so I won't
go through all of them so it's really
great to see you know some bigger
companies you know like folks from
Brooks from Intel and HP and you know so
I've been I've been contributing through
through to Sigma and of course I was at
Cloudera before that but this is you
know we're getting a lot of inbound
interest and I think you know over the
course of this year next year I think
we'll see a major uptick in kind of an
investment from from from the big tech
companies who who want to support
Aero in their and their systems we're up
to 140 contributors on github this is
our kind of JIRA burndown chart it turns
out that not everyone uses JIRA but you
can see that we we kind of got off to a
slow start and then there was an
inflection point
at the end of last middle of last year
and so it's been kind of you know kind
of to the moon since then I think that
trend will continue over over the next
over that couple of years we've made
nine major releases so I'm not going to
bore you with the details of what these
releases but just want to give you a
flavor of what's coming in the project
and how it's relevant to to data science
users so let's talk about computational
libraries because at the end of the day
what this is about for data science
users is making data access a great deal
faster and more efficient making it
easier to use multiple programming
languages so if you want to use Python
and art together this technology makes
that much neo student you know much
simpler and so I don't know if you saw
the reticulate package from our studio
which provides Python integration and
are so having you know kind of Aero
support to be able to move data between
Python and R will make that whole stack
a great deal more powerful so at a high
level you know the way I think about the
problem having worked in this ecosystem
for a long time is that Python and are
built on this computational foundation
that was established in the mid-1990s
we're looking backward from say 1995
everyone was programming in Fortran and
it was you know you said hey wouldn't it
be great if we had interpreted
programming languages that could
manipulate the same code the same linear
algebra libraries multi-dimensional
arrays that we're using in Fortran but
we could do so in an interactive
interpreted environment so hence we had
numpy developed in Python and equivalent
types of tools in R but there's a lot of
problems with the the computational
systems that perform analytics in memory
so a lot of the algorithms are single
threaded there isn't a great deal of you
know the execution model the way that
algorithms are evaluated is is very much
you know one step at a time there's a
lot of temporary data that's produced so
so there's a bunch of problems there and
what's happening is that you look in the
Python Antartica system and people are
you know if your data is small
everything's fine and so it turns out
that a lot of people have small data and
this is just not an issue but as soon as
you start getting into you know
the tens or hundreds of gigabytes of
data you start to get into into
struggles Ville and so and I've been
there and really you think about where
things are going we've got these
machines with tons of RAM tons of very
fast solid-state drives and loss of
cores we should be able to work with 100
gigabyte data sets on a laptop without
even thinking twice about it and so
that's that's the world that I'd like to
I'd like to get to so to have Oliver as
many of our algorithms be multi-core GPU
accelerated we have all this fancy code
generation stuff that we can employ to
make things even even faster there's a
lot of there's a lot of sophistication
that we can bring to the table and a lot
of this comes directly out of the
analytic database world so it's not like
we even have to reinvent wheels we just
look at what the database world is doing
and we adapt those ideas for for data
science use cases so there's a wealth of
literature and learning that we can that
we can bring to to the everyday lives of
of data scientists so so what a lot of
the work I'm running out of time but a
lot of work the next couple of years
we'll be building computational
libraries that that process the arrow
memory format so these will be native
code libraries that are that create
shared libraries C C++ shared libraries
so we can use them in Python we can use
them at R we can use them in Java
through j'ni bindings you know I think
we'll see computational libraries build
and rust and other languages and so
those could also be brought brought to
the table so all this will be portable
code that can be used in any and any
programming language it's plenty of
other stuff we got to do you know we got
to read CSV files everyone loves to read
CSV files but it it has to happen
because it's really important but you
know my goal in the long in the long run
and where I hope you know we we see
ourselves in a decade is that we have
you know portable high quality high
performance libraries that we can that
we can develop the front end that suits
us whether that's an our front end or a
Python front end and we have the you
know the same quality of you know
experience and performance and
scalability regardless of what
programming language we're using so
that's that's all I'm sorry for
for running over time but you know with
so with Ursa Labs I will have a lot more
time and more leverage to work on these
problems so that's super exciting I have
about like a 15 page
tech vision document that you can read
all about this stuff so if I've been
thinking about these problems for a
really long time so maybe you'll have
some ideas and I'd love to I'd love to
hear from you and I if you'd like to get
involved in the development the the best
way is to get involved in the apache
aero project which is on github and you
know we're there to help and we'd love
to we'd love to have you involved
it is systems work so it's you know it's
a lot lower level than a lot of the work
that the data's data scientists
experienced day to day but I found that
I quite I quite like the system's work
so so that's good thank you all
[Applause]
you